all right so swartz Integra has his
comeback movie this Stallone's all like
[Music]
let me show you always don't you know
pull it to the hand
so bullet to the head star sylvester
stallone and it's ultimately his
comeback movie it's like The Last Stand
for sports Nagar but first alone and
this is a total harken back to a DS
action movies it doesn't get more
eighties action movie than this
it's Stallone who's a mercenary and he
gets teamed up with a cop because
they're both trying to go after the same
people because the guy killed Stallone's
partner and now we have our 80s action
cop mercenary movie it is that 80 it is
so 80s that all you hear is Ronald
Reagan aids and boom boxes it's that 80s
now if you remember I gave last stand a
little bit of flak so I was like yeah I
get what they're going for you know I
was supposed to be coming back this
movie really wasn't what I remember him
for but I gotta say bullet to the head
exactly what I like about 80s action
movies this is what I want to remember
Stallone for this movie was kick-ass is
it great know who wrote this I
have no idea but I can tell you this
it's someone who knew how to have fun I
walked away from this movie going
stallone still got it in fact it feels
like he hits harder now than he ever did
back in the day and i got to give props
to the sound people the sound mixers and
the sound editors in this movie very few
times the way ever pay homage to the
unsung heroes who are the sound people
in a movie but in this movie i will give
you guys props sound people in bullet to
the head i salute you
these hits are brutal and they're nasty
that you just feel like they're cracking
bones the bad guy in this movie is the
guy who plays Khal Drogo and Game of
Thrones this guy is menacing and evil
and actually kind of he's kind of a
smartass
for just like you're a big guy and we're
fighting you're breaking each other's
faces did you just throw sarcasm my way
did you a douche but I like that and a
good villain
this guy really played it up he did it
well sometimes the shakey cam gets a
little bit much where you're like
alright we're doing that whole
close-quarter shakey cam thing it's it's
happening right now but it only happens
a few times in the movie
it doesn't actually override that it's
not like you walk away going action was
it was all shaky cam cuz it
wasn't none of that Alex Cross and
that none of that here there's something
about this movie that reminded me of
hard-boiled it's is really nothing like
hard-boiled but there's something about
it that
hard-boiled I think it's the scene where
a bunch of guys had semi-automatic
weapons and they're all shooting at
Stallone and you count your like alright
everyone has shot their gun 31 times
unlimited ammo like hard-boiled and
eighties movies which are awesome that
guys look at Stallone in this movie like
that senile old guy he still thinks he's
young and badass like okay cash but he
does and so you're like okay I guess you
can it's like in last and they wanted to
play up and admit the fact that Arnold's
old and so now this is how it is he's a
small town sheriff and all that come
back but kind of a nerf down come back
kind of way this movies like now still
I'm still young and well he's old
but he acts young but it totally works
for your enjoyment you walk away going
yes Stallone still kicks ass and that's
all I wanted to say sometimes the cop
who's paired up with Stallone he's
ultimately Stallone his partner in this
movie he's okay not like you walk away
gun the Oscar goes to that guy but the
movie doesn't take itself seriously to
the point where you're like you let it
slide yeah things like that can slide in
a movie that's a total throwback to 80s
action movies it's such an homage to
old-school that you feel like griping
about things like that in this movie
would be like griping about Mega Man 9
because it has 8-bit graphics it's
almost the point so a cliched scripts
cheesy dialogue badass Stallone
marketing back to old school with a
really menacing villain and really sweet
fights and action and guns and things
that I wanted to see in a Stallone
comeback movie I will say bullet to the
head is a great time no alcohol required
when I was a kid you were on one of two
teams you were either team
Schwarzenegger or team Stallone when I
was a kid I was always team
Schwarzenegger always thought he was way
more badass but in looking at their
movies now and what they produce and how
they are I got to say team Stallone
dudes just more badass now he hasn't
lost it so how are you guys now that
Stallone and sports a are trying
to make their comebacks now and trying
to get into action movies again what
team are you on
Delon or sports a who's more
badass who's more your guy whoever it is
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you
[Music]